foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
all times
[Music]
oh my God
laughs
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
thank you
foreign
ER with up to 10 random players team up
and must combine the abilities of 50
different characters to win and
completely Loops throw yourself on a
spike and lay down an adorable little
tombstone
Karma zoo is about helping people
working together and Finding Bliss in
cooperation even when things go wrong
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hey everybody this is James Mountain
Community manager here at grasshopper
manufacturer and today for our 20th
anniversary so when do I get to light up
some demons hey what the hell man
hey what's up
Maybe
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
[Music]
hey every demon has the right to pick
the music for his own funeral I do love
a party
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
hey kids it's me your old pal Volbeat
your favorite video game character
remember me I'm back
ten nine eight
seven six
four
three
let's play
for generations of Gamers this is where
it all began
the cultural icon of the gaming industry
more influential than any pop star or
politician
the most famous video game mascot of all
time
devolver digitals very own
volvi
you know him as the star of all your
favorite devolver games but where did
valdi come from many years ago devolver
digital hired little-known designer
Jonathan trotfield and tasked him with
creating a character that could rival
the big names of the day you have to
remember we were trying to compete with
the Heavy Hitters Bank gex Awesome
Possum Errol the air roll bad
and this was no small task
uh yeah we spent a few years on it but
to be honest I don't really remember
drawing it I remember Jonathan showing
us that final design it was a beautiful
moment
that face
of smart brown shoes
and of course
the master stroke is one big hand for
gaming I just never seen a character
with a hand that big
we knew straight away we had something
special volvi was introduced to the
world in his first solo game
field run which went on to become a cult
hit we were seeing the sales numbers
going up and up we couldn't believe it
the demand for the character was insane
I think it's supposed to be a rat and so
volvi went on to star in a string of hit
devolver titles Hotline Miami
Cult of the Lamb
Greece from nomada
Eighth House
my friend Pedro
pikuniku enter the gungeon the list goes
on and on
volvi's popularity had skyrocketed he
was an icon not just for video games but
pop culture in general
[Music]
the volvi merchandise was flying off the
shelves I'm talking clothing
toys
and even a range of what we called
legally edible snack foods
[Applause]
figure out what's in your mouth
but tastes and Trends are fickle and as
the years went by kids began to want
different things from their video game
mascots
we saw the way the market was changing
and we made the difficult decision to
part ways with ronoth we had no choice
we needed to keep volvi relevant
[Music]
cheeky smile now you don't need your
permission to eat a meat Burger even the
big hand for gaming in favor of
something with more attitude
what I have an earache and I don't care
it's graffiti time looking back on it
maybe we went too far
too far volvi 2.0 performed poorly and
the character began as slow but steady
decline
so
we made the decision to quietly
discontinue the volvi franchise it felt
like
I was losing a family member
well a distant family member but it was
still quite horrible
and um
nobody assumed since
[Music]
until now
very very special night I'm your host
Chris Jake and you heard it right folks
I am so proud to present the launch
event for the reboot rebirth and return
of the world's greatest video game
mascot
oh yeah oh yeah okay settle down please
because it gets even better
ladies and Gentlemen please welcome back
valdi's original Creator ronophen
come on Ryan Yes wow
oh my goodness Ron what a moment you are
looking fantastic please tell me bro how
do you feel right now on this momentous
day
very nice
oh wow that is beautiful that ad is
amazing and I for one cannot wait to see
what you and the team at devolver have
come up with so uh what do you say you
want to see it
ladies and gentlemen without further Ado
may I present to you the new and
improved valve
[Applause]
wow
oh my God he is back incredible but how
does he work
I'm glad you asked Chris
well we've taken the heart and soul of
what made Jonathan's character so
lovable but we've given him a very
important new update with the latest
advances in both biotech and machine
learning valve e fuses the DNA of a real
vole with today's most powerful AI
technology that's impressive
can instantly generate brand new fully
playable games based on simple prompts
by the player simple prompts you say
that's right the consumer no longer has
to wait for a bunch of slow programmers
and stinky developers to be
they can use Vol V to play what they
want when they want
here let me show you hey there evolve e
[Applause]
[Music]
generate a game for me how about one
that oh I don't know is a Cooperative
survival sandbox but with Wizards
Maybe
[Music]
listen
and I'll tell you what to tell you
who are they still sticks alone the
hunter the maker and the wild swamps on
the young Chief resin and a weaver of
bone remembers
gay was thrown wide at the horror inside
too high before it was done our heroes
yes everyone
they fell and today
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
so wait a minute
are you saying that game was entirely
generated by Valve e no one has to spend
any time or effort making it correct
there was no real creative process at
all just evolve e and his wonderful
machine learning
oh no well that's a good question
actually that uh well each prompt and
game idea has to be digested by Valve
E's powerful system and so inevitably
there are some waste byproducts
uh so back to the games
um
do you mean to say that anyone can give
valve via prompt
even I don't know
me
[Applause]
sure Chris see for yourself oh okay I'm
nervous now hi baldy Chris Jake
I'm a huge fan of the Talos principle so
I'd like to see something like that but
with new puzzles a grander story and big
beautiful worlds to roam around oh and
I'd like to see that gameplay
right about
now
[Music]
I can't help but notice that many of
these structures are not strictly
functional there's a sense of Aesthetics
of beauty here
[Music]
this place might be meant to test us but
perhaps there's more to it than that
what are we being tested for
our worth curiosity
our persistence
I keep thinking
why puzzles
the just their symbolic value
the thing about puzzles
[Music]
they can be solved
yeah oh yeah
wow now that looks like the kind of game
I could really spend my disposable
income on thanks volvi
and what happened to this big pen
uh-huh
and the best part is that to create a
game with valve e you don't need any
game experience or any of that type
stuff who here has interruptive creating
their own game I have right you there
yes
[Applause]
all right okay all right well oh and
okay be careful be careful no please
please be careful sorry this is just I'm
such a big fan
all right so do you have a game idea
you'd like evolve e to generate uh okay
um how about a super weird walking
simulator where you control the
character's legs independently from his
body maybe there's some guys in horses
heads and possibly there's even a
mountain
right
um but let's see valvi what could you
rustle us up
[Music]
eight
Nate
Nate Nate buddy family meeting let's go
are you bringing a food not right now
not right now you are literally killing
him with these people
you just want to
just want to no he's 35. I want him to
have some kind of discipline
maybe if you can hear my voice
what the hell
what's up
[Music]
foreign
let's go back in time to when you didn't
no I I was just trying to catch it with
my uh sorry you tried to catch it I
thought it was starting to go and I just
tried to just kick you thought I'll give
it a good kick to counteract the fall
yeah I was just trying to steady it I
might go over yeah but you might have I
might have you might have overstated it
no it's just a little oversteady well
it's not steady now no well see you
later uh wanker yeah
[Music]
um
[Applause]
but you don't own any of the
intellectual property and you still have
to buy it okay give her a big hand
brilliant
so what happens if we bring a pro into
this let's give Volby something really
special here
[Applause]
watching live and can I just say what
you were doing out there incredible I
could not be more excited to be part of
whatever this is and thank you we're all
massive fans of your influencing
what sort of prompt would you like to
give valve e here okay try this volvi a
much anticipated sequel to a hilarious
online co-op game just more gameplay
more levels just better all around
okay Barbie show what you got
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
human fall flat too I know I'd love to
get my hands on a copy of that who
wouldn't right yeah come on well ladies
and gentlemen now that you have all met
the new and improved volv e it's time
for him to meet with you as we connect
him to devolver's Global Network of
Gamers yeah that's right come on what's
connected his powerful technology will
be an open source tool free for us all
to use wow that is generous here we go
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
merchandise right now buy it now a
Dimensions devolver Buy It Now
[Music]
thank you